hey guys welcome back to the stage and
is Mortal Kombat time apparently it is
in fact X no moral Kombat 10 so these
are important things to get right now
I'm joining the stage by Ed and it's a
pleasure to have you here it's good good
great it was great to see more combat on
the press conferences as well yeah I
always loved those like the CGI they're
really brutal CGI trailers you put
together yeah we're actually gonna have
a live demo so we got two guys through
the back you were gonna beat each other
up so let's jump straight to the
gameplay now you can talk me through
what's happening well talk about what's
new and more combat ex lots of things
like that yeah you know we brought six
characters to the day three here and
four of them are brand new to the Mortal
Kombat universe and then we have our
kind of staple Scorpion and sub-zero
Devorah she's like this weird spider
buck lady right yes half insect F human
and she has all related to you know with
their stingers and that's one of our
more unique fighting combatants
ferreters another one which is you know
this kind of big monster with a little
lady on its on his shoulder who gives
them commands yeah yeah so and and then
of course you know the classics Cassie
cage is Johnny Cage isn't it just take
just to cut in here you've got this
variation that's ours before character
variations as ever every character in
the game has three versions all of which
plays differently from each other so
they have unique moves unique you know
strategies and whatnot so you know a
matchup in a character is in in this
game is much more variables than just
you know sub-zero versus Scorpion and
sub-zero a versus absorbing sub C so
it's very very wide range of character
so it's not just a static then these
these variations so how does it change
it is it your different moves you can do
yes exactly yeah there's a number of
unique moves that each variation has
that the other ones don't you notice
scorpion right here he has these swords
on his back only that version of
scorpion has sort on his back and he can
use them in combat for a number of his
attacks so you're gonna see him swinging
the sword there
you know so it's like only that version
of scrubbing it do it
and whereas ferret or fights with this
little lady on his back and he uses her
you know he can swing her in attacks and
he can use her as a projectile as well
so there's a lot of and you know when he
gets hit she gets knocked off yeah it
gets knocked off and she jumps right
back on his shoulder so right now she
just stabbed him
that's called a pain and game move and
so he starts bleeding taking damage but
he's inflicting way more damage so it's
a bit of a but thank God she got you so
what else is new then apart from these
variations what else have you brought
need for more climax
you know the environments is are playing
a bigger role then they have an immortal
combat in the past you know you can
actually use them for what we call
environmental leveraging so on the on
the left there you'll notice that you
can see us scorpions just long jumped
over this one yeah one of those pier
things and it allows you to you know
strategically position yourself into an
area that you are more useful for you're
gonna notice this hook over Barrett or
you can actually jump up and swing there
yes attacking there so on you notice
that the sea will bring up a dead body
occasionally as you can grab that out of
the air and call it alright yeah I think
I saw that the Presto position yeah yeah
so on the left side here you see no
scorpions ran up the wall kind of
getting yourself out of the corner so
though you know that layered on top of
the character variations layered on top
of normal combat nines
you know meter with the x-ray and all
that stuff
it really feels are kind of deep this
floor come on thanks you may finish me
want to see yeah document
yeah this school fatality with tandem
fatality their eyes that's pretty that's
pretty brutal guys yeah okay that's
gonna hurt Wow yeah I can tell like next
Jim Fixx ahadees yeah that's what I want
to know I'm gonna be scared at the
answer is even who comes up with it with
like these brutal fatalities where these
ideas come from whose twist steed mind
yeah let me see you I'm scary to me we
have fatality meetings we have the
funnest meeting what's by 9 o'clock are
you gonna fatalities exactly so people's
coming to come into a room with little
pieces of paper with stick figure things
or they'll get a reference from a movie
or though that you know do all the or
they stand up and kind of act it out and
so it's it's a fun and then I have to be
the bad guy like if something crosses a
line I kind of like you know yeah I'm
sure there is a line but it's it's not
obvious where it is because it's just
it's just like a gut feeling you kind of
get like you know that some of the stuff
that we've done we've wondered about but
there's been a number of things that
have been presented that you know you
can you mention anyone who didn't make
the cut or did you could you like tell
us anything what did what didn't make it
no they're so bad that it's kind of like
that I don't even like talking about
okay that's pretty bad yeah yeah you
have a fatality being I wanna kill along
this yeah great
so em who's got the board she's the I'm
gonna spidery - sank lady and which
variation is this this divorce is called
up a broodmother and and it was re
Broodmother you can tell you can see on
the top of course is the name of them
and you could tell visually you could
tell which one it is because she doesn't
have the foot on and so each each
variation has something you know you
notice sub-zero there on his grandmaster
1 he has that that medallion on him and
you could tell from there like which
variation of the character it is earlier
you notice that the they picked up the
old lady who's just gonna
and user as a projectile as well so Sub
Zero here uses the opponent's entrails
freezes and the kind of chance that may
become really trails freezes them and it
steps in the yeah yeah yeah so those
those you know always only have these
big kind of fun moments in the game but
you know on top of it is we're adding is
really cool the variations really add to
the depth of their are done more x-ray
attacks and finishes in an X I'm sorry
if you adding a ton more like x-ray
attacks and finishers we have a ton boy
yeah yeah oh yeah yeah there's there's
yeah it's it's this is a great kind of
ending with this fatality what happens
the bugs kind of aid away at their skin
then she steps on the so am what are you
guys like what were you guys doing in
terms of narrative can you talk in a
told by narrative in jerk these the you
know Mortal Kombat's our last few games
actually Mortal Kombat and injustice
have had you know really elaborate kind
of single-player campaigns where the
player kind of fights through all the
battles and and determines the story
going going forward we're gonna continue
in that vein with this game but this
game covers a number of time periods you
know it has it has elements from the
right after mp9 it has you know five
years ahead fifteen years ahead
25 years ahead so he's these things like
Cassie cage which is Johnny Cage and
Sonya blades daughter and you know you
get you get an idea of that dynamic of
her and and so it's really cool and that
in it were not necessarily telling the
story linearly we're doing in periods of
time and so it's great to see the
characters kind of maturing over time so
and you guys have got the stamina bar
this time around as well
right I'm sorry you guys got the stamina
bar this time yeah right yeah how does
this work
yeah you know there's a number of things
that you can do in addition in this game
that you couldn't do it before one of
them is running you can actually run
into into your opponent okay and so we
use the stamina bar as a way to limit so
you can't just be running all over the
place infinite tomorrow we see kind of
filling out the loan the body exactly so
so you know there's there's new
mechanics that are in the game that you
know you couldn't do it in the last one
and it's kind of like a way to regulate
it so what is this M what are we running
this on right now which McQuaid share
hardware are we playing the Sun right
now I I think this is a ps4 version and
this version it you know it's great it
runs at full 1080p 60 frames per second
so you get a lot easily our most
sophisticated presentation that we've
had in a mortal combat games x-rays
x-ray it's pretty nasty
so what's them what's this war going to
a photo can enable them to do I'm sorry
sorry sorry it's quite light off stage
here
what's the workout and version a lot
like how's that change total cast
abilities total con yes this this
version of portal con he has this
gigantic sword on his back and he uses
that a lot in combat the other two
variations don't have that sword so
again it's it's it gives him a slew of
moves that he that he can perform just
in that variation a little bit more
reach than then he normally has so I'm
also I was reading that a this time
around you've actually increased the
combat speed a little bit of roll call
bags is that right yeah it plays a
little bit faster than the last Mortal
Kombat game did and and then and then
again it's a lot more variety of things
that can happen with the the you know
matchups and variations yeah yeah cool
guys if you're watching home right now
and you have any questions then as
always the best way to do that is to
tweet at me at kam fries Rob they sort
of handle be on screen any sec
that's C a.m. if RAZR OB there it is
and now let's see this fatality here
comes fill it to kneecaps to the heads
this is gonna end well
bubble gum what's Wow that's Sam yeah
how'd you come up with that was like you
know they'll throw in this bubble gum
with me yeah but that one was that one
wasn't mine that was that was one of our
designers came up with that one was the
one I came up with of course what is
that what is that it's and can we see it
Corp Ian's I think I think we've seen it
in the the the gameplay was that had
been released a welcome in case some
people watching home haven't actually
seen it can we can we get scorpion
involves I guess we can but I got the
back out of the place yeah I just check
Twitter to see if you have any any more
questions but what's it like being back
at e3 with a new Mortal Kombat game it's
very exciting you know when we released
the the trailer video which was more of
like an announced trailer it was
exciting just because of the response
was ridiculous you know we had like you
know seven million views and in just a
few days and then we did the the
gameplay one which answered a lot of
questions as far as you know the details
of gameplay and the response has been
like you know bigger than I I could have
even hoped for so it's just so exciting
to see Google excited about what will
come back and speaking of a response
questions coming over Twitter already so
I'm gonna throw someone easy to you
that's okay absolutely well first up we
have our they're different is a good one
are there different fatalities for each
archetypes you know we thought about
that but I think we really wanted to
give everybody a chant every character
never here is gonna have multiple
fatalities but we really wanted to have
them accessible to everybody
that questions been asked again okay
this does that mean voice any of the new
characters shown here well I'm still the
voice of scorpion they get over here and
all that but a lot of the stuff in like
the the story mode and all that is is
professional actors now I'm not a
professional actor scorpions pretty good
what else we got here okay what ninjas
are gonna be in more Kombat X like we
can we can confirm at the moment our
Scorpion and sub-zero I would be
surprised if there was no more than that
and the final and the final roster did
you have a you have a favorite character
I can ask this question my favorite
character scorpion it's only it always
has been I guess you know I think that
there's a lot there's a lot of history
with that character and and and I'm the
voice of scorpions so yeah the same it's
just quit just checking at Twitter again
see what else we got coming in
here we go so talk me through this stage
here this is like the dead pirate ship
stage or something how does this fit
into the the narrative oh yes you poor
we can't talk about that kind of
spoilery bit yeah tell me about this
stage the this is this is the cold and
it it's one of our prettiest stages you
know the water early sign of shows off
the whole next gen graphix that we
couldn't you know we couldn't do before
and it has a number of you know kind of
opportunities that that pose to the
player I guess we might see another
fatality here classic art removal and
then so thinking about next generation
so how much has been working with this
new hardware what's it enabled you to do
that you have enough to do with morale
cam before beyond just like really nice
vision yes we always considered like
just the entry point is is a better
visual presentation and so so as as far
as you know the the character variations
and and things like that I don't I don't
attribute them necessarily the next Jim
but what I do I do think of them as a
necessary step that we have to take with
every every game we really want to
introduce something new that hasn't been
done before and and and kind of
separates it from the previous version
of MORTAL KOMBAT
there were a number of features that
people really liked the meters with the
breakers the enhanced moves the x-ray
and we layered on top of that with the
variations and the backgrounds and
leveraging yourself and really feel like
this is gonna be the the kind of deepest
gameplay mechanic that we've had we
talked about multiplayer at all are you
guys talking about multiplayer at this
point we are obviously we're gonna have
an online component and we're gonna have
a number of online modes one of which
you know we're not giving out a lot of
details but it is it is a persistent
online game that everybody's gonna
participate in so we're really excited
about giving details later about that
yeah
so it's certain to be something that
you're gonna you know we wanted to
participate in everybody will be part of
it and I I'd love to get more details
now but it's it's gonna be cool make
sure you come and tell us when you do we
want to know tell me about I want to
know what's like what's a swarm queen
allowed to vote to do is it IG IG
producer named devorah's alright Devorah
yes so what's the swarm Queen very each
like the she's like the projectile
version and she she has a number of you
know she could send this bug along the
ground to attack the opponent she can
you know she can throw this bug so she's
all about throwing distance and and and
projectiles and keeping you know keeping
distance weather all of them have a the
she has the stingers that you can use
and the the the ferret or on the right
the girl isn't or the the lady isn't
riding on top of of her he she's just
kind of standing on sand as a
cheerleader so he becomes more of like a
more classic brawl or something like you
know like a solomon grundy from
injustice or you know a big big brooding
character and he doesn't have the
projectile moves where he throws the
lady at him so I didn't need three
different variations of each character
huh that must have made it quite
difficult for her balancing it means are
you tackling that problem well we're
definitely we're definitely gonna get
you know kind of like the Pro Evo MLG
all those those players in the studio
really they're gonna be you know beating
on the game and showing us you know
helping us balance it as much as
possible with three variations of
characters as exciting that is that also
comes with it is the added the added
challenge of balancing all those
variations of characters together some
more wonderful bone-crushing there and
yep through the eyes wow how did she get
back up well I'm just gonna go back to
Twitter and just see if we got any more
questions
okay so we've got other questions so
what about storyline like how does it
tie in so if you like play it all the
way through Marko about nine and you
know how they're gonna tie in together
the story does have scenes that that
that are very close to the end of MK 9
but it also jumps ahead five years jumps
ahead 10 years you know 15 20 years and
so it's not told in just a linear way
there there's you know there's there's
that there's jumping back in time and
whatnot so so it is gonna elaborate and
give a lot of history as to like what
happened to the characters afterwards
and what happens on a long-term basis to
the character so more questions on
Twitter here do you mind if I just threw
some more absolutely the fans these are
the big questions they've got now this
one might be one you can't answer but
I'm gonna throw it at you anyway so Alex
is asking who is Sub Zero he was cyborg
last time and he's an ask ed please yeah
you know as anybody who's really kind of
followed the Mortal Kombat story you
know sub-zero is part of a link with one
clan and he is he is one of many sub
zero's so there have been some zeros who
died there have been other ones come
back so it's not the representation of
sub-zero has been a number of different
people and the story mode will will tell
you exactly which one this is
so Jason om is Conquest mode back it's
Conquest mode back not in this version
so a lot of people are wondering about
about characters I know you were only
revealed me sick so far but maybe you
can hint here like more Club out in the
past have obviously brought in you know
like you've had kratos you've had Freddy
Krueger can we expect any like cameo
type perishes there's a thirst I think
there's a very decent chance that we're
gonna have some guest characters you
know and Mortal Kombat 9 the Freddy
Krueger download character was the
highest-selling of all of them so yeah
yeah and an injustice the guest
character being scorpion was the
highest-selling of all those so so that
that's obviously people are kind of
voting with
yeah yes I was pretty hopeful I think
you'd say that
oh yeah are there gonna be any stage
fatalities very likely very likely oh
wow so cool freezing of a chest cavity
reaching in breaking the spinal column
and then ripping the person that's not
possible I don't believe that's possible
nice a lot of I don't think I don't
think your real thoughts are you alright
what else we got loads of questions
coming in are there gonna be any
unlocking and Mortal Kombat X so like
crypt was in Mortal Kombat 9 but lucky
what I say it's gonna be any like
anything you can unlock I think and the
unlockables I think is always saying so
like crypt was and more Kombat 9 well
well we haven't we haven't announced
what what the actual feature is but I
you know I can't imagine a Mortal Kombat
game without unlockable items gonna be
in this one there will be another
allottee I could say that when with all
well it could be brutality it could be
babe allottee it could be you know let's
talk about variations one more time so
you mentioned you didn't decide to give
variations as their own specific
fatalities but does it change like
x-rays and open up new x-ray movies and
things like that no it doesn't change
the x-ray move but it changes their
special moves quite a bit dramatically
you know like like there's a whole
series of moves that that one it's
mainly for the combat to hand at the
moment to moment combat you know
fatalities and x-rays while the attack
is used you know a lot of it is is the
visual the visual Wow of it
a couple more couple questions here so
this someone's just really pleading to
for us to show scorpions fatality did we
make that happen
oh yeah see we got here that's actually
not very good question
it's just so many coming through it I
love them with the same we're just gonna
organize them through here okay well
it's a question for ants well Sonja's
x-ray make the cuts well Sonja's x-ray
make the cut
well Sonya hasn't been announced so I
suppose I I guess I I couldn't confirm
or deny it was there anything you that
we've not really covered so far in moral
Quebec so you really want to talk about
you mentioned the stamina bar we've got
a different variations of characters
like what else are what people aren't
thinking about picking this game up
what's what what's again awkward yeah I
mean like I said there's six characters
here and each has three variations so
there's actually 18 variations of the
characters here you know Cassie cage
right here she has the SpecOps one and
she can call call missiles in from the
sky you know that attacked the the the
player and so you know again all these
kind of unique moves at just that one
variation of the character uses it's so
much that we haven't even seen that
we've even demonstrated yet so that's
what you know what's so exciting if you
know if a game has 25 characters there's
75 versions of characters up in the game
and and so the mixing of that what I'm
so excited about it is it just creates
such a bigger palette it's like giving a
you know an artist canvas and giving
them five colors and buy brushes versus
a hundred colors and a hundred brushes
it's just what players are going to do
with these things is is the most
exciting to me meaning you having us
stage or show us here been great it's
been it's been pretty brutal
yeah a little bit sick yeah it's a great
way to end my time on the samsung stage
today but don't go anywhere I will be
replaced by who's waiting in the wings
it's handsome man Danny or Dwyer the
Irish legend so he's gonna be on stage
I'm gonna go off have a break and be
back on the Gainesville station
but so don't go anywhere daddy he'll be
in the seat with some more games seen a
bit